yo what is up everybody it's procedure
mad Luigi back inside of The Witcher 3
and in this video I'm gonna be showing
you guys a quick and very easy way how
to get basically infinite XP and like
infinite levels for your skill points
and just it may be a too low loved look
for your uh certain quest you want to do
this video is gonna show you a quick and
easy way how to gain levels fast so what
you're gonna want to do is you can want
to go to vellum gonna go off the coast
of vellum the west coast it's gonna be
there's gonna be a marker there if
you've been there called the coast of
Rex and there's a ton of ships in the
water I'll show you later on in the map
where specifically it is gonna swim out
to the ocean there's gonna be guarded
treasure on an island and there's gonna
be these three grounders that spawn next
to that island now these spawners will
these drowners these drowners will spawn
in infinitely what you have to do though
to get them small infinitely is every
time you kill him just swim around a bit
not looking at the drowners it's kind of
like if you've seen the monster nest
glitch or the monster nest video that i
put up or anyone else is a monster this
video it's basically the same thing you
have to take them off your screens
rendering and bring him back and they'll
respawn as you can see on the mini-map
to check if they're responding now you
when you do this you want to go
underwater pull out your crossbow you
have Auto and meter crossbow chances are
you're gonna one shot these drowners and
you're just gonna shrek them as you can
see I'm killing them really fast I am
really over leveled compared to the
drowners these are three level 10
drowners and I think they will always be
level 10 and this is a this really good
way to get XP it is I must know it is a
lot better to do if you're a lower level
such as like level 5 to level 20
probably because I'm like level 30 I'm
level 31 I think in this video so every
single one of these drowners is giving
me one XP that is a very low amount of
XP so this is the lowest you can get but
I'm giving one XP because I'm 21 levels
above these level 10 enemies that's how
you get XP base top level if I kill like
a level 50 enemy and I get all mark
speed and if I kill level 10 enemy so as
you can see it's working pretty well if
you're a lower level you can get stuff
like seven
p-per drowner and that is a lot of XP
especially since it doesn't take as much
XP to rank up at lower levels okay you
can see I need 2000 XP to rank up I
remember at other levels I only needed a
thousand XP drink up so this is
basically the trick it's it's a quick
easy way to kill drowners and get XP
from the drowners if you stay back from
the drivers they shouldn't be able to
attack you as you saw when I started
this video
I got hit a few times that was I was
just kind of getting into position I
didn't know exactly where the dramas
were gonna spawn and but you see once I
got into my flow I'm just running
through these drowners again all my one
XP is doing a lot I'm probably not gonna
use as much since I'm I'm kind of over
leveled at the moment not through this
exploit it's just that I just have over
leveled myself so I don't want to get to
more levels since then the missions
aren't gonna be any fun so you can see
this is the map this is valid it is the
west coast and right above the you can
see the guarded treasure right there
kind of like in the middle of the map
right above the coast of wrecks
yeah Coast of wrecks marker and that's
gonna be basically the exploit um I made
a video about how to extract up XP fast
before and maybe you guys had you
chances are if you guys have seen my
channel right now if you've seen this
you've seen that and I know a lot of
people didn't like that wasn't the cup
of tea which I I do kind of understand
I guess people were looking more like a
quick exploit rather than just me
telling them to play the storyline so
here is the quick exploit of how to rank
up quickly it's killing drowners that
infinitely small and getting some XP per
driver and it's really easy you I don't
think you can leave the drafters maybe
you can loot the the bottom of the seat
but it's it's not too big of a deal so
guys hope you enjoyed this video if you
have make sure you check out my other
videos it shows me that I should keep
doing what I'm doing and I'll see you
all later peace